mi è il precursore prende tutti
bentornate solita stories
oggi vedo aprire tutti gli slam che mi
avete regalato ai firma copie
innanzitutto grazie mille per essere
venuti firma copie sono stata
felicissima di incontrarvi se volete
vedere tutti i regali che mi avete fatto
al firma copie andate a vedere il link
che vi lascio alla fine di questo video
quindi per una spia in questo video dopo
potete andare a vederlo perché sono un
sacco di cose pazzesche bellissime ma
oggi andiamo ad aprire tutti gli slide
siete pronti mettetevi comodi patatine
pop corn e e alla fine del video potrete
votare quale quello che ti è piaciuto di
più iniziamo subito allora iniziamo
servizio da questo slime da even sui di
un po tra l'altro così slime hanno fatto
un viaggio nei abbastanza lungo sapete
ero in tour per sei sette giorni più di
viaggi in aereo quindi spero che non si
siano rovinati troppo un bel colore
quest lime e rosa con glitter e sono
uscite un po di bolle date si sono un po
folle di un po fame e il profumato
elastico a dei clipper dorati molto
carino questo slime si è indurito poco
poco ma quello basta aggiungere un po di
densi strizzo un po di crema
quindi questo e book live di haven
grazie mille life slime questo è uno
slide fatto da legni ed è viola vediamo
un po
guardate che per colori intenso
wow è superfluo famoso che un po grossi
ucciso di un po il colore bellissimo
prossimo bluesy slime allora è super
allungabile che bello e ha anche dei
leader dentro è un bellissimo questo
glossy slime super allungabile facciamo
uno su il burqua davvero bello grazie
mille per questi live
allora questo slime è da ginevra vediamo
un po
e uno slam jam pesca ea pari glitter
dentro vediamo abbastanza morbido one ha
tantissimi glitter dorati molto
estendibile anche questo bello ma rimane
un pochino più rigido forse se delle
triremi dentro molto bello per su live
grazie mille a dentro esistono anche
tipo delle frutti nei grazie mille per
questo il claim poi con diamo un altro
slime da ginevra
questo è chiuso con lo scotch quello
viola praticamente la maggior parte dei
colori
la maggior parte degli sly mi avete
regalato i viola lusso perché nei
commenti perché ma guarda te ci sono le
palline blu e viola che carine e quindi
un trancio fa tanti suoni frangi c'è
anche qualche stellina trattata da viola
e una stazza di celestino forse super
carino presso sliwa e non si è indurito
comunque anzi è molto morbido
grazie mille per questo simon veramente
bello il suo slang quest lime e da
matilde e asia e mati games per pranzi
eccolo qua appetiti dei suoni
ma sì che fragilissime fare di sliven
grazie mille per questo slime questo è
un perno flyng fatto da licia vediamo è
un bellissimo color rosa infatti è
pronto per lato
vediamo un po un morbidissimo sentiti
soli ed è anche profumato
ma è bellissimo colore stupendo parte
che è super allungabile davvero bello
[Musica]
bellissimo da un bel grafico per questo
slightly mad da chiara vediamo dai viola
vediamo un po sembra morbidissimo a un
bel colore
eccolo qua e là mossi anche questo
schiuma da barba perché fa tante bolle 0
carinissimo che la sterile questo slime
purtroppo non c'è scritto il 9 quindi
stream ivi nei commenti se sei tu che
l'hai fatto un live arancione in pratica
tante palline per sul time vediamo un po
wow è una consistenza molto particolare
sempre che ci sia quasi del play dentro
ea tante palline la roma stato uno slang
di questo colore tra l'altro molto bello
e molto morbide morbidezze morbido e
allungabile bellissimo grazie questo
slime purtroppo l'ho già scritto il nome
più kroto ci siamo un po queste
scatoline sporca nina a questo purtroppo
affollato un po durante il rialzo e ora
lo recuperiamo e altri serre e vallive e
anche un po lucida un po glossy
che bello grazie football slang slime è
stato fatto da valentina viviamo
guardate che bel colore e tipo di acqua
grigento metallizzato sicuramente
metallizzato vediamo un po ragazze come
il sito
wow bellissimo davvero bello grazie
questo la jma è stato fatto da licia
purtroppo se un po show
basta aggiungere un po di attivatore
sarà fatto il viaggio appunto il colore
è molto molto carino carino anche che ha
aggiunto le perline però ora devo
insomma devo aggiustarlo un pochino
bettelheim resto fatto da londra
attendiamo che bel colore color pesca
sofficissimo ma è un osmosi un come si
chiama domenico mente come si chiama con
l'altro picco di slide scrivetelo nei
commenti
a parte che ha un profumo incredibile
ora ha un profumo incredibile oltre che
appunto e soffici simo forse un play che
è stato ammorbidito molto con la crema
con questi il profumo è incredibile sa
di pesca un famiglia bellissimo grazie
londra lo slime è stato fatto da daniele
andiamo
abbiamo uno slide viola il punto non so
se e perché a voi piacciono tanto di
slam viola oppure perché sapete che
piacciono a me che le avete forti scrive
nei commenti perché la maggior parte di
quelli a fatti viola comunque sentiamo
un po e un po grossi e dentro ammesso
delle palline e dei pezzetti di
cannuccia per fare i cloni è rimasto
molto morbide si sono anche dei glitter
[Musica]
ma aveva un sacco di voli tra l'altro
wow
grazie da linee per facetime slime ha
fatto lo hanno fatto alice e viola un
pattern che sia un po abbiamo un blu
eccolo qua e un blu elettrico
wow vanello anche queste molto morbido
molto simile a l'altro color festa
bellissimo supersoft il bellissimo anche
il colore grazie mille
allora questo slime è stato fatto da
giorgia del colore che bello è anche
super lucido il colore davvero stupendo
questo celeste verde acqua
[Applauso]
davvero bellissimo grazie questo slime è
stato fatto da giada e giorgia guardate
quanti cuoricini vediamo il colonia
bellissimo e proprio intenso patate e
pieno di pulizia qualcos'altro qua
dentro c'è ordine c'è un personaggino
era stato affogato dentro eccolo qua un
personaggino uno slam e molto grandioso
visto che si sono tutti i cuoricini
fatica tantissimo nel colore stupendo
grazie al live è stato fatto da asia e
matilde e super di interrato viola e
dentro a altri che letterini uomo
fantastico bellissimo grazie allora è
questo per questo giaime pensione su
dove purtroppo perché guardate un po mi
a proporla in verde io purtroppo non mi
ricordo chi mi aveva portato questa
scatolina con lo slang firth e hanno
voluto carico air force che fred e viano
corrotta lo slime un verde totti con
tono blitz quando l'ho aperto quando ho
fatto il video appunto in cui aprivo
tutti i nostri regalini mi sono sorpresa
ai orizzo anche perché non me
l'aspettavo profilo slide verde comunque
grazie lo stesso anche se è verde è
comunque bello a una bella consistenza
qua abbiamo uno slime fatto da benedetta
e sofia viviamo o purtroppo cus lime si
è un po sciolto vedete si è creato un po
di liquido quindi devo provare ad
aggiustarlo non prova ad essi emergency
le mani se non faccio un casino che sul
tavolo
sicuramente è stato il viaggio purtroppo
però insomma devo provare ad aggiustarla
e mi è stato fatto da milena e colore
abbiamo un arancione intenso un super
arancio non ho mai fatto molto di questo
colore un super arancione tipo mattone
come dei glitter che all'inizio grazie
one e bel colore super allungabile
grazie
nel frattempo mi se
attaccato un po di sliven nella manica
del copri spalle e mi sa che non
riuscirò a salvarlo ditemi voi secondo
voi riesco a salvarlo non lo sono un
pezzo
e comunque questo slime è stato fatto
dal caja e diretta pensate quanti
clipper è un bellissimo celestino
profumato in bellissima celestino e un
po grossi che bello davvero bellissimo
grazie slam
purtroppo non c'è il nome e rosa celeste
un bouquet morbido un morbidissimo rosa
e seles e con l'inter
io ero bello grazie questa slide metà
aurora viola a di questo super viola www
ebbene questo penso che sia fatto con il
club e sofficissimo puri glitter dentro
juan bellissimo
wow davvero super line è stato fatto da
pietro c'è scritto scusa se non è bello
che che vediamo un po che carini noi una
clamorosa con le pagine bianche
purtroppo se è un po rovinato pensato né
in rialzo con quel tanto carino grazie
pietro quasi un'altra tranche purtroppo
non ha nome
molto carino anche questo sia un po in
diritto e colore bellissimo grazie slime
è stato un fatto da alice vediamo slime
decorazioni
molto bello grazie sarebbe stato fatto
da fare anche questo viola ci sono un
sacco di perline e infatti fa molti
sogni grande e sentite sta perdendo
comunque super carino grazie allora
forza non hanno ma penso che non sia uno
slam
ci sono un sacco di cosine da mettere
nello slime quindi decorazioni quali
invece non c'è il nome purtroppo vediamo
un po che slime è l'humus muslime bello
si è un po indurito purtroppo molto
carino grazie minuten serials line fatto
da alessia vediamo vediamo un po
ecco qua carino
[Applauso]
molto bello il super allungabile grazie
mille ci sono due live in uno di a volte
riesca ad aprirli e se l'ha fatto ad
aprirlo questi slime sono stati fatti da
sara degli anni prima queste piccolino
che blu che bello e fatto con la colla
trasparente e blu notte molto carino
c'entriamo l'altro corso invece viola
superficie roso guardate quanto e
glitter osò wow sente con la folla
trasparente super carini grazie slime
non c'era il nome purtroppo qui non so
che li abbia fatti
vediamo qua abbiamo uno slice mutuel
viola intenso abbiamo uno slam
trasparente con le palline se un po
indurito comunque trasparente con le
palline bellissimo anche questo grazie a
questo slancio il nome purtroppo
purtroppo si è indurito un sacco ops
purtroppo è duro non so se riesco a
salvarlo questo slime l'ultimo slime è
corretto da vittoria e viola che non
fosse aperto però è successo qualcosa è
successo qualcosa di strano qua dentro
perché praticamente lo slime
attaccato alla scatoletta e ha preso un
po di ruggine della scatoletta e non
molto in merito però preferisco non
toccarlo appunto perché si è rovinato
così e non vorrei che mi si attaccasse
appunto tutta la cosa della scatoletta e
sulle mani ma vabbè pazienza grazie
comunque
potevi sa fare con il trend è piaciuto
più di tutti la sua tempo resta in
stampa ai ringrazio anche chi mi ha
portato questa con la trasparente che
apposita per l'am purtroppo non c'è il
nome ma ti ringrazio tantissimo non vedo
l'ora di provarla ringrazio tutti per
gli slide per le altre così le manca
solo per essere venuti vi ringrazio
tantissimo e vi mando occupazione enorme
potete vedere ora qua in queste altre
quattro cartellini degli altri miei
video tra cui i regali dei firma copie
ciao